hallo leute ich bin hier in meinem home
office wo möchte ich heute einige
vokabeln rund ums arbeiten am laptop
vorstellen
los gehts also ein schreibtisch ist
immer relativ leer
ich habe eigentlich hier in rom an
laptop das wichtigste das wasser am café
auch sehr wichtig flade wert von laptops
natürlich nicht mehr arbeiten dann
manchmal brauche ich auch auf höherer
wenn ich keine fünf konferenzen bin ich
nutze auch manchmal eine externe maus
und auch sehr wichtig an der externe
festplatte so er für den laptop
aufklappen und starrte passwort das kann
ich euch leider nicht zeigen und los
geht's am laptop haben wir die tastatur
mit den verschiedenen einzelnen tasten
hier zum beispiel die enter-taste die
leertaste und noch viele mehr
ein trackpad die lautsprecher und einen
bildschirm akku leer
gerade ok zurück an die arbeit
[Musik]
lässt das layout von kari kari hallo wie
sie da machst du dran der ersten leben
kommt eine episode so verließen german
aufenthalten rein gefunkt hier wie
geht's dir als gut
ja transport viel zu tun wie immer was
möchtest du denn sie macht dringend
motors und zwar von unserer sympathie
zinsmeister da hast du noch foto
screenshot irgendwas gemacht hätte ich
ein paar ganz gute jahr wollte die ja
schicken was ja ein bisschen vom ist
dringend bringen die sie nachher fast
schon so viel angst haben nicht gut wenn
du gewinnst die minimal über schickste
richtig los ja und sonst geht er ganz
gut wir haben hier zu tun
arbeiten sollten ich denke was auf sie
zu tun
wir machen hier eine episode über das
arbeiten am laptop
okay man arbeite mal rein alles klar
da jetzt zeigen wir euch mal wie man
seine daten auf dem desktop sortiert
schauen wir mal wir haben wir
verschiedene partner nun kann ich meine
momente und fotos in die richtigen
ordner verschieben
genau die fotos von kahric die schick
hier gleich mal
ich bin noch gar nicht mit dem internet
verbunden also erstmal wlan aktivieren
das richtige netzwerk aussuchen anmelden
so nun öffnen wir ein neues e mail
schreiben den text partyfotos
andersherum es geht
die fotos kann ich als anderen städten
haben also anfangs während die fotos
anhängen
so jetzt öffnen wir ein neues dokument
das nenne wäre dann schreiben wir da
jetzt können wir das dokument sichern
das liegt jetzt auf dem desktop und kann
auch schon mal gleich gucken ob wir das
als pdf jetzt ablegen als pdf sichern
und schon ist es auch als pdf gesichert
ganz wichtig wo man sachen verschickt
können wir die pdf öffnen hier drückt
man die datei wenn man einen drucker hat
leider keinen druck aber man könnte es
machen
theoretisch darf bei uns episode rund
ums aber in einem laptop
ich hoffe ihr habt einiges gelernt wenn
wir jetzt noch mehr deutsch lernen wollt
dann probiert doch mal unsere app sie
länger aus dort könnt ihr in einem
vokabeltrainer systematisch alle
wichtigen deutschen vokabeln von a1 bis
b2 lernen ab einen schönen arbeitstag
und bis bald
[Musik]